what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off hunter Horsley is the
founder and CEO of bitwise asset
management in this conversation we
discuss his time at Facebook and
Instagram
we lay out the case for financial
advisors to get exposure to crypto for
their clients we address the common
detractions and we even discuss alien
invaders and Mars colonization I really
enjoyed this conversation and I hope you
do as well alright guys
bang bang bang bang I've got a hunter
here with us I'm super excited to have
this conversation if you like hunter has
been on the front lines of talking to
investors about Bitcoin and crypto
currencies for as long as I have and
been in deep in the weeds so thank so
much for coming to do this
hundred percent I'm so so happy to be
here with you alright before we talked
about crypto though we both worked at
Facebook and the the Facebook ecosystem
or family right talk about that what
what uh what got you to Instagram Athens
restarted right that's right yeah so
came out of the Wharton School went to
went to Instagram worked at Instagram
for really a magical moment there's no
substitute for forelock I was there at
70 million in revenue and I left it a
billion in revenue and they gave me the
easy projects which turned out to be the
big projects that we just knew would
work and that was about 300 million in
revenue that I got to work on these are
advertising products it's actually funny
just as an aside I sometimes get little
moments of DejaVu because in the early
days of Instagram ads something we would
hear from big advertisers Unilever
Procter and Gamble was we're not sure
that these are real ads you know we
can't you know there's a lot of
magazines or not billboards you know not
TV I know that you're saying that the
numbers look good but how can we know so
we would get test checks from these
giant advertisers for a year just to
make sure that the money didn't
evaporate what is a test check a test
check yeah a test check for depending on
the size the advertisers could be a
million bucks or
million blocks of adspend but not a real
allocation of their budget because again
is it's these these ads in an app on the
phone and this is I'm supposed to take
some my TV budget and put in an app I
mean to my my my son my daughter uses
this but I you know I just I don't have
been an account I don't have any care
yeah exactly that's everything and at
the time I think when I joined Instagram
it was 200 million users or something so
it wasn't a billion let me know and sort
of unavoidable like it was today like it
is today so anyways this is it's kind of
funny how you know that that pattern of
sort of skepticism despite the evidence
that existed in in at and digital ads is
of course something I think both of us
see some symmetry with with
institutional allocators and
professional investors is they look at
this base but anyway so so so was there
was a product manager working with as
you were with engineers data scientists
engineers designers etc what was your
biggest takeaway from working there well
one of them is there's no substitute for
just a giant change in the world right
you know when you see something like
Instagram and you see the numbers doing
what they're doing and you see the
conversion numbers on ads and the CPC's
you know it takes a little while for the
emotional realities to catch up for
their competitors to realize the
advertisers to realize but it takes a
while to slow a train and so if you see
a train that's up to speed that's a
really rare and valuable thing and I
think it's also what's so compelling to
many people especially from from from
the tech world about crypto and Bitcoin
you look at the numbers and you say this
is this isn't credit is a phenomenon I
think this the second thing I don't you
know just just problem solving and you
know how to professionally you know work
with a team and and hit metrics and it's
the one thing that they're really good
at but I don't think people can
appreciate because it's like Oh Facebook
was successful of course it was gonna be
successful right or I saw recently like
Balaji and a bunch of folks were
debating on Twitter the Instagram
acquisition right people like oh what
are you talking about like how that
wasn't a contrarian view
and he was like uh news flash that was a
pretty a pretty controversial thing that
they didn't imagine I wasn't I wasn't
there at the time but how many uses they
had they 288 80 approaching 100 million
they shelled out a billion bucks they
only had 12 employees no revenues I mean
but in hindsight what an incredible and
prescient deal you could argue the same
thing obviously of YouTube is an easy
one to point to you could argue the same
thing for whatsapp i I think at this
point you put but I think that a lot of
those like Instagram and Facebook both
had very similar DNA's in the sense of
like we're just gonna figure it out
right and like we can look at the data
we can come up with products like we can
test things like we're gonna figure it
out and that I don't think is very
common in a lot of companies yes but
these large technology companies like
that is a common theme throughout them
yeah well said all right so you're there
you're working with we're both biased so
like we're just gonna on the bias as far
as people in the world and these massive
user bases like I always try to explain
to people like when you go to work every
day and you're like wow there's a
billion people retouching this product
right and we're gonna make we're gonna
run a test on 1% of the population right
maybe like one person yeah that's one
percent of a billion Jesus yeah what was
like the first time you ever heard of
Bitcoin or crypto or blockchain and like
what was your reaction yo I just I just
want to just want to linger on on that
point then the testing for a second I do
think that's something that sort of
you're forced to encounter at a place
like Facebook or Instagram that you
don't necessarily need to encounter at
other institutions is you know so I
instagrammed I worked at Facebook
Facebook two-point-five at the time it
was one or one and a half billion users
most your users are not Americans so
you're when I was there
87 percent were not in America yeah I
think today it's something like 200
million of the 2.5 billion are Americans
so so it forces you you know in in
academic institutions when you when you
read the news you know that there are
different types people different
societies different you know legal
jurisdictions but then at Facebook you
have a small you know maybe you're on a
team with 20 people and you're designing
for 150 different kinds
and you know 130 different languages and
I think that that embeds you know an
understanding of the sort of scale of
the Internet and the heterogeneity of
the people participating and there again
I think you can sort of see the insane
beauty of something like Bitcoin that
you you create this this standard layer
across all of that cacophony they're all
and I'll even take a step further it's
more of like a 3d view of the of the
world and what I mean by that is like a
lot of people think okay great you've
got to come up with the latest you know
add product or something right and maybe
there's some language component or some
like cultural component you got to be
cognizant of but also like what are the
things that I took away was I forget
what they called it you'll probably
remember but there was a place at the
Facebook campus that you could go and
you could test your product on all sorts
of different connectivity environments
yes yes it's called the connectivity lab
so it was like what is it like to have
like an Android phone in Indonesia where
they have 3G time- screen yeah all
that's the standards issues I mean to
get a clean shot where you have a large
group of people on the internet all with
roughly the same interaction
he's just so is so easy and you've got
to do it like I remember one of the big
things that we had so I was running the
growth team for Facebook pages and we
had this huge upshot in usage but it all
came from mobile web in less developed
countries so it was basically they go to
not an application not on their desktop
but on their phone to facebook.com and
we had figured out that they were all
using phones kind of like the t9s so
rather you know where you have to click
a bunch and so they would try to scroll
over and to get two pages it was like
three rows down yeah we literally just
moved it up so it was less clicks for
them to scroll over and you should shot
up those things matter and you're like
man that's pretty simple like you just
made it easier for them to get to it
yeah right yeah but it was the numbers
it was understanding the devices
connectivity like all these things and
when you start to think that way it's
worse
probably too early in a lot of the
crypto applications to the layers of
fiction are immense you know if the
difference between not having to scroll
and having to scroll can be up that huge
of an impact then differs between using
meta masks and not using meta masks
pretty big big pretty big giant yeah so
uh so yeah I think that that that that's
definitely a present part of the
friction in the Curtis Basin friction is
very real for sure alright first time
you came across crypto Bitcoin
blockchain yeah so my journey into into
crypto we actually had the opportunity
myself my business partner co-founder
and starting bitwise guy named Hong kam
did softer security in the Korean
military where Google knew him from from
universe offense vania with close
friends and we actually this this rare
opportunity to some investors offered us
money to quit our jobs and just
prototype something just to work on
something and where it was this the the
Google / Twitter / Facebook mafia it was
it was and they were both X cool it was
it was it was it was a virtual Garg and
a lot Gil can we can we talk about the
the angel investor mafia that's going on
there these so for those that don't know
there's each technology company in
general is overgeneralization but they
all have a group of folks who have a
bent towards
angel investing courage early-stage
technology and they are notorious for
finding usually younger talent at the
company that they don't think is gonna
stay and be a lifer and either one
saying here's somebody go figure
something out or people know who they
are and go and pitch them and say hey
I'm gonna leave and go do this would you
like to invest yeah they've been
fantastic investors over the years
because they've got great talent very
early like all the ingredients you need
to be a good angel investor and so they
came to you guys and basically said
here's some capital there's a bit of a
longer story to it I don't want to use
it too much of our time where is the end
of being a Facebook retrospective
podcast which was just fine but you know
the short of it so I left and and and
hung and I raised some money and then we
were working out of you know
room putting our heads together and put
a typing different concepts and if
you're too software people in San
Francisco at the beginning of 2017
before too long someone says hey do you
remember that Bitcoin thing yep and I
was like gosh I think I bought some on
some website at some point and of course
that website was coinbase com
I don't if you've heard of it I'll look
it up it's like gem 9 but I bought some
at some point a 2013 or 2014 totally
forgotten about it and it was actually a
friend from from Wharton who was working
at a stat stat ARB hedge fund and he
said hey there 40% spreads in markets on
this stuff and we were just like that
doesn't seem I don't seem right so so
our journey into crypto is we we started
out by arbitrage trading and that's not
what we're doing today but I think that
everyone sort of has that one project or
experience that gives them pause to to
look at it more seriously and for more
concerted amount of time and that was
what it was for us in in February or
April March that timeframe we started
arbitrage trading and that gave us the
opportunity to learn about different
protocols meet some people who are
building block chains deal with the
ecosystem of trying to buy different
assets you remember at that time I think
coinbase was only brokering Bitcoin in
aetherium I think and also to think
about why are why would we root for this
you know I think when you work encrypted
for long enough you forget that at the
outset it's not obvious to everyone if
this is like the team you want to root
for like de novo it doesn't necessarily
sound like something it sounds
complicated sounds like it's gonna
complicate everyone's life like you know
your mom's now gonna have to deal with
not just cash credit and her portfolio
but now this is a whole nother set of
things she's have to deal with is that
something you want to root for and so
you know so he gave us give us a moment
to think about that and where we where
we landed was thinking that this this
could be one of those trains that's hard
to slow down and could be one of the
most important you know breakthroughs or
pieces of progress in technology over
the next decade over the next two
decades and we just felt like we
love to contribute something to this
we'd love to be part of this this feels
like the type of thing that's going to
get a chapter in the history textbook
there are other things we you know we've
worked on insurance for cybersecurity
incidents which is a growing industry
and a great opportunity concepts
obviously haven't come from Facebook and
Instagram concepts around entertainment
experiences social media but then you
know I think we just looked at wait a
minute this is not only not only is
there opportunity here to create
services that are valuable and build a
business in doing that but also maybe
this is maybe this is gonna change the
world a little bit so well it goes back
to the idea you can bet on products you
can bet on teams you're looking better
on markets right and when you bet on the
right market the market can carry it
pretty far yeah yeah even if you mess a
lot of stuff up if you bet on the right
market at the right time yeah you're
gonna be good hands yeah yeah
Annie Ratcliffe the founder of benchmark
capital and CEO of wealth front has a
great quote that goes something like bad
team good market market wins good team
bad market market wins so so yeah I do
think there's something to that so to
close the loop you know so there we are
feeling like wow this is really exciting
thing playing out right in front of us
and we have time you know to be building
things and we were talking people at
crypto and a common refrain that we
heard in March or April of 2017 from
people who are executives in tech people
who are you know in financial services
you know they have investable money
they're tech savvy they're financially
competent they're they're confident in
making their own decisions we heard you
know I'd like to invest in this crypto
thing but I don't have time to figure it
all out and to be constantly monitoring
it and I'm not sure which one I'm
supposed to buy and we heard this enough
time from people like that again this is
not like your uncle who and I don't know
your uncle so no you know I hope your
uncle doesn't take offense at you yeah
you might fit the bill here but you know
these are people you would expect to be
on the sort of upper tiers of ability to
figure out their folks who are normally
in technology who understand user
experience yes they can deal with some
friction yeah and the common friend was
you know I'd like to participate I just
I'm not gonna spend if I you know I
looked it's too complicated and and and
so we said wow that's that you know
we're hearing
and and we realize that there is from
our perspective a piece of market
infrastructure that was missing at that
point in time you had and even still
today and this might frame up a little
bit how we think about what bitwise is
trying to contribute you had on sort of
one in the spectrum for enthusiasts who
wanted to you know trade it throughout
the day or who wanted to pick specific
assets or participating I SEOs you had
great tooling being built out you had
unit you could download coinbase you
could you could get more involved the
crack in where you can even take margin
you could do esoterics you could hold it
on a Ledge or a treasure you could do
research on on chain effects and so you
had an emerging ecosystem for the person
who was excited to spend the time on the
other end of the spectrum you know for
very wealthy families some of them knew
a guy who was just spinning up a hedge
fund like one of their friends just
decided to go ahead and spin up a fund
but in between you had most of the rest
of the people who were like I'm
interested enough to consider something
I'm not interested enough to you know
decide between the following apps the
following coins to upload a driver's
license to request it you know
withdrawal in crease and I also you know
so so what we realized was missing is
the ability for their financial adviser
and you know for them to use a
conventional mutual fund ETF interval
fund what you know what have you yeah is
it really uh and as I previously
mentioned the introduction right we're
obviously investors a bit wise right
huge fans of what you guys were doing
and the way I think about it is it's an
access yeah component right it's I've
got to do some education I've got to
learn in terms of how do I think about
this in my portfolio why would I get
exposure how do i sighs it all that kind
of stuff but then once I've made that
decision that's where all the questions
come in right and this is a something
that looks like smells like acts like
exactly how I get exposure to other
assets and therefore I'm comfortable
because I'm already taking quote-unquote
risk by going into something new right I
don't want to take risk by going to
something new plus going into a new type
of vehicle plus having to sign up for a
new account like all of that stuff just
compounds that makes it harder in her to
get there I think really when I look at
what you guys are doing it's just how do
we break down the frictions to access
and make it look and smell
just like everything else you do that's
right right you know that's exactly
think of ourselves as an infrastructure
company or as you know from from my tech
friends you know I would say we're like
an API company but the API is so
important that we put it into a legal
structure and call it a fund yeah
but yet we're trying to empower people
to lean on the same financial
professionals that they use to manage
investment grade bonds emerging markets
commodities natural resources high-yield
debt etc and to be able to go them and
say yeah I think that I want to do
something here and they said okay no
problem
yeah so I want to get into kind of like
the argument for crypto in so much
portfolio but before I do that give us
an update just any metrics or kind of
milestones you can share from yeah
absolutely itself to give us a sense of
kind of where you guys are yeah
absolutely
so bitwise today were about 20 people
based out in San Francisco
we're boutique all we do is index funds
and access products for particularly
today you know financial advisors
multifamily offices we meet with some
endowments and and and others but you
know the conventional people are most
interested in those types products and
then we do a huge amount of education
work I you know I mention to you before
we do about 10,000 converse excuse not
10,000 2,000 conversations with advisers
a month between events phone calls et
cetera we never disclose or historically
we haven't disclosed the assets and the
fund but I can tell you that we've had
inflows every week for the last two
years and yes Phil's listening at home
that's good I can tell you that that
additional subscriptions are well in
excess of redemptions I think that we've
seen in life of the fund something like
7% of investors redeemed from 2017 to
today and to our knowledge it's the its
largest public index fund in crypto
today so that's a little bit the firm
the you know you're very familiar with
our firm if there are listeners who
aren't familiar with us you know the
other thing that I usually like to
mention is that we've tried to assemble
a group of people who straddle
backgrounds in software and a
traditional asset management so we start
this conversation talking about our
backgrounds in tech
and obviously your partner mark usko
marries that with a background in asset
management and asset allocation for us
we today have brought on a number of
veterans of the ETF space Matt Hagen our
head of research 15 years is one of the
foremost experts on ETS co-authored the
CFA exams book on on ETFs are Katie Orr
CEO was former senior vice president
head of portfolio management and New
York Life Investments which is a giant
convert conservative shop before that
editing exit cue which did liquid
alternatives before that direction make
our head of distribution ten years at
iShares from 2001 to 2011 Russell
Investments and then most recently was
the head of distribution for Deutsche
Bank's ETF business grew that from 70
million to 20 billion assets so I think
that for our clients and when people
think of the the firm what we hope that
they think of is a professional group
that can straddle those two perspectives
and a partner for building building
their understanding and then deciding
how they want to play it yeah and also
some people don't end up playing it to
our vehicles some people talk to us to
build that understanding and end up
investing through venture vehicles which
is I would say one of the very popular
approaches today so that's a that's what
about the firm and yeah focused on
advisors have this market access
vehicles spend a huge amount of time on
education Matt actually jokes that we're
an education company that happens to
have index funds and and then the other
thing we're known for is this ETF filing
that's so we'll get to the ETF filing in
a sec but I want you I want to do you
spent hours and hours and hours going
and talking to our AA's yeah wealthy
family offices etc yeah and we are not
giving investment advice here but
basically we want to give people kind of
a peek behind the curve because there
because most people listening to this
are not going to be part of those
conversations and so help me understand
kind of like what's the what's the
argument or what is the education that's
happening yeah kind of in those like I
think this kind of like intellectual
hand-to-hand combat yeah where you're
walking into a room whether
a meeting with like an RA a and a team
work could be walking into the culantro
dinner with their clients etc what does
that look like yeah so let so let me tie
I want to tell you that this sort of the
three things that are motivating
advisors to come into the space and it
might be fun to talk about some of the
common questions we get I know that you
get as well before even doing that for a
second I want to sketch out who is that
who is this advisor person if they're if
they're advisors list in the podcast we
love you and you know what you do but
you know believe it or not encrypt or I
think very few people are actually
familiar with financial biases and I
actually tell you might get a kick out
of this you know there's a number of
venture firms it firms investing in our
company and you'd be surprised by the
number of venture firms who aren't aware
of financial advisors so with that
having been said I want to before I
describe how they think about the space
I just want describe who they are so if
you if you sort of draw out the
landscape of cohorts that are investing
in crypto today I think by and large you
can you can map them into four buckets
the first is self-directed individual
accounts so these are people who are
investing their own money making their
own decisions they might have bought
lifts IPO through the Robin Hood account
because they like lifts and they heard
good things they trust themselves with
their money they're nimble these are the
first movers in to crypto some people
call them retail um but it's also you
and me like it's people making everyone
does this in some amount that audience
in the u.s. controls three three to four
trillion in assets and by and large they
use coinbase Gemini if they get more
involved in all retail cracking yeah
exactly they might use a ledger they
might do research on core market cap
then you have financial advisors who
I'll come back to then you have
institutional asset owners so the
pensions endowments and foundations they
manage 24 trillion in the u.s. that's
600 billion with the endowments 800
billion with the Foundation's and and
you know 222 trillion with pensions
which are giant and and Morgan Creek
digital is is famous for for having the
first partnership with a with a pension
that had the courage to you know
publicly undertake adding this to the
portfolio that audience tends to prefer
active managers is happy to take the
Allah quiddity in many cases and today
they work with a lot of venture
like Morgan Creek digital like injury
sin like paradigm electric etc then one
over you have so 24 trillion there one
of you you have the institutional asset
manager so so there would be like you
would think like drw or what do W is
actually a different piece so we'll set
that aside that's done yeah exactly
exactly those people by and large day
are not yet in the space okay so there's
a different cohorts and the reason I say
that is because I think sometimes in
crypto when we talk about investors
depending on who you're imagining you
into it differently how they'll react to
something what might be on their mind
what else this might be trading off
against and what solutions they're
looking for so we have a self-directed
guy in the first into crypto we have the
institutional asset owner which we
talked about and you guys sovereign
wealth funds and insurance companies in
hospital systems etc to that in between
you the financial the financial adviser
manages 22 trillion dollars in US on
behalf of individuals wealthy families
and high net worth individuals and that
can be anything from a Wells Fargo
Advisors it's down the block or JP
Morgan private banker but a huge portion
of it is also what we would call Ras or
independence Mark Zuckerberg famously
works with iconic out in San Francisco
the Rockefeller family works with a firm
in New York called Rockefeller Capital
Management those are those are advisors
or multifamily offices and what they're
doing with their clients is you know in
some ways the same way you work with a
physician on your health you work with
this financial adviser on your money
which is I think for everyone
three priorities are their family their
health and money and so many people
choose to work with a professional on
their money and that's the financial
advisor and the financial advisors
helping you think about what are your
cash needs this year
do you have retirement goals is somebody
going to college you're gonna have to
support aging parents and then they're
orienting the investments you make
around those liquidity time horizons etc
and so that is just the frame that I
want to set for describing the
conversations we have with those people
but what we are working to do that
audience generally doesn't use venture
and they're definitely not using apps it
has to go through their existing
workflows their infrastructure and and
that tends to be ETF's mutual funds and
then a whole a whole set of work you
know workflow so we're working to build
a bridge to that audience is a giant
audience and from my perspective also
crypto cannot be successful as an asset
class if mainstream people can't rely on
that financial professional to handle it
for them I think it's a beautiful thing
that that individuals like ourselves
have the enthusiasm to create accounts
to to make investment decisions on our
own
to interpret the volatility but I do
think that that enthusiasm enthusiasm
has a half-life and we even see this
sometimes you know people who invested
some money in 16 17 18 getting a little
worn out and exhausted something else in
life becomes busy and then they ask
their adviser to handle it for them the
same way the adviser again handles you
know the options they have from some
tech company the high-yield debt the
private credit that you know everything
else they say can you just can you
handle so that's the audience were
focused on that audience has a lot of
clients they're very busy they're
thinking about everything the thing
about equities you know up 20% plus is
your gold up 18% they're thinking about
you know we're 10 years plus into an
expansion
they've been worried for last three
years that the the party is over and you
know we need to start to get defensive
but you can't come out of of risk assets
because then you miss the 20% return on
equities this year and your client is
you know confused about you so so that's
all swirling in the backdrop and it's a
very busy time for the adviser and then
we come along and say you know we'd love
to be helpful and talk to you about
crypto if that's something that you're
interested in so that's that's where
they're starting there's a huge set up
to your your initial question which is
what is the what is the case for them
there's three reasons that advisors
think about crypto today the first is in
relation to sort of what I just
described their clients doing it and
they work for the client we do a survey
every year we commissioned a survey
that's benchmarking surveil and advisor
attitudes and decisions around crypto
we'll have a new one coming out in
January last year's survey advisers
reported
third of advisors said that their
clients were investing in crypto without
them without their oversight another
third said that they don't know so the
first reason and this you know there's
three components to what advisors thing
about but the first reason that advisors
are thinking about crypto is because
their clients for doing it and they're
there to help their clients their
clients are pulling them into they're
pulling them into him and also what what
can sometimes happen is the client gets
in trouble like they gets imported or
they get locked out they forget their
password or they get busy and they say
to the advisor can you deal with a forum
or they have to pay taxes and they say
the advisor can you pay taxes and then
he advises oh my gosh what is this we
need you buy what was the cost basis how
do you decide these do want to keep it
do you not want to keep you know all
these things
so advisors are incrementally month
after month getting pulled into it
because of their clients and they want
to protect the client they want the
client to achieve their the financial
goals they want the clients to pay their
taxes they don't want their clients to
get you know hacked lose their passwords
etc I was trying this one advisor he was
telling this funny story about his his
client said hey I'm gonna buy some I I
mean this very wealthy client I'm gonna
buy ten million dollars this Bitcoin
thing I just download the coinbase app
but I'm kind of confused can you help me
and so so he sent his password to the
coinbase app to the advisor and then the
advisors in the coinbase app trying to
like get the withdrawal limits pushed up
so you can wire ten million you know so
this this sort of like newsflash for
those that don't have ten million
dollars in trying to get into the
coinbase coinbase will not let you put a
million dollars yeah
or you know or no just one other cases
another client who she had four hundred
thousand dollars in in in Bitcoin and
she did gets imported so her phone got
hacked shame she lost control of her
coin base account and and then she asked
her advisor for help so the first reason
that advisors are looking at crypto is
because they serve the client and the
client is 40 million coins accounts like
the client is doing it already and they
want to know okay how can i if they're
gonna do it I want to support them doing
it how can I do that in a sustainable no
risk you know it's it's hard for them to
discern the difference between bases is
is is an incredible service in their
minds coinbase and quadra CX are like
the same thing and so they're like I
just don't know which
these things so they want it they want
to help they wanted to be sustainable
they wanted to be secure and they're
dealing with a lot of complexity it's
not their expertise and they don't have
time because they're also dealing with
the you know equities and and and
figuring out or you figured out fixed
income and freaking out 2020
first reason the second reason is what I
think you know you you you read about
it's more theoretical more academic
which is just objectively what it can do
in a portfolio you do a portfolio
analysis it does very compelling things
so and this is the re way for
non-correlated asymmetric assets that's
exactly right
so so we have a study and others have
done studies if you if you do a 1
percent allocation into the bitwise ten
the bit x over the life of the index and
you rebalance it into a 60/40 portfolio
so very standard portfolio 1% allocation
it added 1.3 percent to the annual
return of the portfolio and it reduced
the volatility it's funny how like
modern portfolio theory works huh right
people are surprised by that and and so
you know I think some people look at
that and say wait a minute this can help
me accomplish my goals I'm sure that
this is what's going through the pension
spine it's not that they picked a team
they're not rooting for something
they're saying we we have a funding goal
we have something we're trying to
accomplish this portfolio and I'm
looking at the math and what I'm seeing
here is that I can take minimal risk
I can I can even diversify some of the
portfolio and I have a reason believe
that this upside here so the second
reason is that all append to that for
financial advisors specifically there's
this thing moving in the background and
the thing we mean in the background is
markets are in a very weird place right
now more generally this year actually I
think just a month or two months ago
Morgan Stanley came out and said they
think that 6040 is basically dead as a
standard asset allocation why their view
is that assets are way overpriced
and that correlations are gonna you know
conventionally bonds are negatively
correlated with equities that hasn't
always been the case that wasn't always
the case in the 20th century that was
mostly the case in the last 30 years of
the 20th century they predicted over the
next ten years a 60/40 portfolio will
return 2.8 percent that contrasts with
historically the historic
average over the last 100 years is 8% so
what they're saying is this time it's
different
something has changed we could we could
discuss what might have changed asset
prices the injection of capital through
quantitative easing and other measures
but you're more instantly saying this
Bank of America came out and said this
GMO which is a macro analyst firm
expects negative returns from us
large-cap equities as well as US bonds
over the next seven years you've
probably read the pieces by Ray Dalio
this year what are you Dalio is a big
corner doesn't even realize it is really
sometimes you read that stuff and you
think gosh well said but you know
statement in his most recent I think
it's from November six thousand words on
LinkedIn god bless him from publishing
on LinkedIn especially given how you
know difficult it is traditionally to
get bridgewater research he says you
know something effective you can't rely
on cash and bonds as a safe store value
for your money so so the adviser is
thinking about all these things and what
a lot of them are seeking to do in
response is you know you can't hide in
cash for a few reasons you just heard
the case that you can't hide in bonds
and and yields are not attractive
anyways and there's anxiety about
inflation in high-yield so what do you
do alternatives is what a lot of people
are looking to particularly in the
advisory community it's in that context
that crypto becomes a solution to a much
bigger problem that advisers have right
now which is okay why so I'm naive I'm
gonna look silly if I just stick 60/40
for the next three years despite all of
these credible sources telling me that
that is not a legitimate strategy for
what's coming but what are my options
you look at alternatives and in in that
consideration set crypto is this magical
thing you you you don't have to
reallocate your your entire US equities
portfolio you don't have to you know
diligence specific venture firms you can
simply take a 1% exposure
get off zero as some people say I hear
who came up with that but they're deeply
influential and and and and introduce
you know these favorable things to the
portfolio demonstrate to the client that
you're doing something and it's liquid
mmm
so that's this and do you feel like the
advisers as they're thinking through
those three reasons for crypto yeah
they're further ahead than the clients
or the clients are further ahead than
the advisor right like where do you see
the enthusiast client has done more
action and the advisors done more
thinking okay interesting so you know
the client the client heard that XRP is
the next big thing or the dream is the
next big thing
this of course I'm generalizing so this
is not always the case of very
sophisticated individuals directing
their own portfolios and accounts but I
think you know the advisors have
approached this from a position of oh
whoa whoa you know different
counterparties it's it's moving you know
a lot in short periods of time and do
you find that the advisors are hey okay
I get this I think I should have my
clients have exposure to this let's
start with like ten basis points let's
go to five hundred like like how do they
think about I've gotten over the hump of
whether I should do it or not now I've
gotta think about sizing yeah yeah
it it depends a lot on the advice but
also depends a lot on the client so what
we usually see actually is the firm's
that we work with they have one to five
clients that they know are like other
ones that are invested in crypto who
have the right risk appetite and from
there it's it's like it's like twenty
five to one of the half basis points
there are a few who are very either the
client is very passionate about it but I
would we we don't we don't see I think
you know one to two and a half we don't
see much outside the the third thing I
wanna mention so advisers have a million
things to say about advisors pump the
first thing but this is what we do all
is I love it I'm here to learn we're
traveling around the country you know
doing that today the first thing is that
they're responding to the client comes
in and says taxes
lost you know lost my password trying to
buy it on companies not being successful
I'm gonna pull you in
yeah a Pullman the second is they're
looking at the numbers and they're going
I gotta do something about the the asset
allocation I've got here but I'm not
sure what to do if I going to cash again
I'm gonna miss the returns and then you
know my clients ask me why is my
portfolio not returning as well if I go
an alternatives this is this is a pretty
you know uncharted territory and I'm
gonna have to deploy into things that
maybe aren't liquid and you know small
sizes it can do interesting portfolios
that's the second thing
the third thing for advisors is advisors
care about attracting new clients by
demonstrating particularly for the
independent advisors things that they
can do that the old guard can't so if
you're an independent you're trying to
win clients from UBS you know all the
people who are course who are turning
their nose up at crypto is or your
competitors for winning new advisory
clients differentiates the RIAA from the
RA down the street
yes exactly from the wire house in
particular from from the Wells Fargo UBS
Bank of America and at some of these
firms the the advisors at those firms we
want to do it
they're just hands are tied by the much
larger institutions so the independence
the reason that they generally went
independent was to be more nimble to be
able to serve the the needs of the
client a more bespoke way and to be more
progressive in what they could offer and
not have to conform to JPMorgan wants
you to distribute JPMorgan funds to
JPMorgan advisory clients and so the
third is business considerations they
want to they want to win clients the
other aspect of that is they want to
retain the next generation of their
aging clients and the next generation is
a millennial and the millennial is
almost more bullish on crypto than they
are on t-bills I see two groups that are
pulling those advisors and the first is
I'm a young I'll put an air quotes
self-made because I don't even know that
means anymore in this world but there's
somebody who has become wealthy without
inheriting the wealth right right and
they're usually on the younger side and
so they're into this stuff and they're
pulling their advisor and the second is
what the situation you're describing
which is somebody else made the wealth
the person now has inherited yeah and
hey my family made all their money in
real estate yeah I want to do something
else I want to make my own
name right or I'm personally interested
in this I want to divert some funds you
know my my grandfather died so he's no
longer around he you know he would buy
Bitcoin if he was here right that type
of stuff and it feels like the common
thread through both of those is it these
class are usually on the younger side
yes more so than the 60-year old client
who's you know retired and you know
quite wealthy but they're still pretty
much asking a lot of the questions we'll
get into yeah I don't see them jumping
in as much as maybe the younger people I
think in general yeah at this point you
know well well well trodden thing but
you know Millennials tend to be the
driving force to the millennial stay 23
to 30 8 something like that 23:38 Wow
yeah that's a big gap all right so let's
go through I want to play a game of I'm
gonna throw out detractions that I've
heard ok in a lot of these rooms some of
them I've never heard a single
detraction about all right and so come
from the endowment world but I think you
and I have spent a lot of time doing the
same thing of just get people in a room
yeah here's the kind of a case for this
ask me your questions yeah right the
first one is security in custody yeah so
I heard that somebody stole somebody
else's Bitcoin why would I buy Bitcoin
or other crypto they can get stolen from
right well how do you think about that
yeah so I mean so this comes up quite a
bit and off times people will point to a
story like Quadra see yeah literally
today in one of our sessions
Quadra CX was was brought up this you
know some Canadian exchange getting
hacked or somebody lost their their USB
and and and and lost their funds my
favorite has been the guy in Korea is
that what any of the guy in Korea and I
had asked him in North Korea or South
Korea so so you know I think the
beautiful thing about crypto you know
for much of your audience is you have
the option to hold these things
yourselves I think to the adviser you
say this is one of the ways in which you
can add value you the adviser is helping
your client parse the landscape of
different ways to hold this exposure
from you know the exchanges
to the brokerage apps to the venture
funds to the the today the sort of
enterprise great institutional
custodians like fidelity bit go I gotta
give shoutouts to all my favorite
custodians now don't I
they're all in there they're all in
there any tons of great custodians
they're all super super sharp but so to
MIT but too many tinea so back many
professional allocators they're
operating off of a snapshot of the world
that they took in November of 2017 and
in November of 2017 you know there was
basically Kingdom Trust which they
hadn't heard of Kings trust pioneer for
the industry great firm but they hadn't
heard of it and so all they really knew
of is people holding things on USBs and
on these on these apps they're not aware
that today you can hold it an insured
regulated custodian and that they'll
hold it offline and they won't even put
it into a trading environment and so so
there I you know I think the point that
we make is just that for many clients it
makes sense to work with an industrial
custodian like that a lot of people will
argue it's so volatile right it it went
down a bunch and recently yeah right
there they won't exactly know the price
movements to a tee but just it's really
volatile and a bunch of people lost
money or somebody I know long thoughts
yeah
volatility isn't in itself an indication
that something's about investment you
have to ask yourself why is volatility
happening was the volatility mean for me
the volatility is happening because
people don't agree on the value of these
assets and it's a very nice and
controversial space the analogy we like
to give is you know people often compare
Bitcoin to gold we wrote about this over
the summer you know I think the apt
comparison is Bitcoin to gold but not
gold of today but gold of the 1970s when
the Bretton Woods system ended and the
US came off the US dollar came off off
gold as a backing for international
redemptions you
unclear to the investment community if
gold would stick around Keynes called it
a barbarous relic maybe it was time that
we would shed you know this piece of
antiquated monetary history and just
move on from it and so there was a
period in the 70s where there's a lot of
volatility because some people said no
no this is a thousand years of a track
record being valuable this is an
independent you know store value another
you said no no this is worthless metal
and and now it's not even the you know
being used to back that the dollar and
in in in the 1970s there was a year ago
lose 120 percent there's another year
was down 30% it ended the 70s up
thirteen hundred percent mm-hmm after
the 70s those discussions those
arguments were had the volatility played
you know people you know expressive
points of views in the market created
the volatility and we landed on the
understanding of gold that we have today
and cents and gold returns on average
you know something between one and two
percent a year so the volatility in
crypto I think is is similar it's it's
that people are working through what is
this thing what is the value of this
thing is it here to stay and that's
causing causing the price to move the
price is the volatility is moving in one
direction over the last ten years the
average daily volatility Bitcoin has
come from 10 percent to around 3 percent
so we are forming a a tighter band of
consensus the other point I make about
volatility which we talked about a bit
earlier is if you'd in the portfolio
context it's a real boon what's
important is that it's it's being
volatile in different moments then your
equities are and that your fixed income
is and and as a result of that as
mentioned before 1 percent allocation
rebounds quarter leave the the bitwise
10 reduced the volatility
despite the volatility of crypto reduce
the volatility of the port this is a
really important point I think a lot of
people who aren't well versed in finance
or just having spent the time to kind of
learn about this Modern Portfolio theory
there's a really big importance on non
correlation and on if you put a lot of
assets into a basket that had the non
correlation or are all volatile at
different times you actually are diver
specifying the risk yep right so the
idea that hey AIESEC this hyper volatile
thing and I put it into my portfolio
well the odds that you have a bunch of
other things in your portfolio that are
all hyper volatile and are driven by the
same value drivers is very low that's
right that's right and that's where you
get the correlations and then obviously
my favorite example is in May of 2019
when the trade wars are all raging on I
mean literally the world leaders are
tweeting at each other all stuff right
there's a lot of political and geo
uncertainty the Bitcoin correlation to
stocks and gold went negative
oh so when negative point nine to the
sp- point eight to gold and it was up
55% and so it was this it was this weird
situation where we talked about non
correlation but actually went the
opposite right it went to the negative
correlation and so when you see those
moments it goes back as I'd give like
the the insurance the schmuck insurance
or the the chaos head yes all these kind
of things that I think in the cryptic
community now I've become more accepted
advisors have never even heard of this
stuff right right yeah I think that's
some of the work you guys think is
trying to get them to understand that of
course yeah and and and so into your
point in those moments that that's
really able to have that negative
correlation and the other thing about
volatility you know a million thoughts
and everything but the last thought on
this is obviously we feel this way
because we serve advisers those are our
clients principally but it's it's also
one of the reasons that it's so valuable
to have advisers managing this for
clients if you open the eye of the coin
based I'm sure you have the Columbus
have you haven't you the first thing you
see will see is the price the 24-hour
price chart of the movement of the price
people are not well matched against
daily price volatility they don't know
what to expect
it's it is emotionally scary 2% drop
looks big on 24-hour chart yeah yes so
so so I think the other meaning the
other implication of the volatility is
advisors can really add some value some
very basic value which is just to
insulate their clients from bad trading
behavior in the same way that you know
if they were day trading their Netflix
position
they probably would have a suboptimal
return for the year because they sold in
bad moments so so I think volatility is
really essential to the asset class I
think it doesn't intrinsically make it a
bad thing in fact because of
correlations is a good thing for
portfolios but it's also a reason that
advisors can add a lot of value the
government won't let this happen they
they're gonna lose power and regulators
or the the law enforcement somebody's
gonna step in and shut all this nonsense
down yeah well I mean so I think there
again we live in a sort of a very
different world in 2019 than we did in
2017 so if you know the mental model
people have is that you know regulators
of the government are sort of a parent
who heard a loud noise in in their kids
bedroom in 2017 they started walking
towards the door at the end of 2018 they
opened the door and they saw the mess
and you know the SVP subpoenaed everyone
and their 25 charges and but today where
we are in 29 so that that hat that's
happened across of course there's lots
of different regulators in different
places but FinCEN NY DFS the SEC the
CFTC even you know this summer Congress
through the lens of Libra are all
staring it in the face they know what's
happening obviously the SEC set up fin
hub the CTC set up lab lab CFTC so I
think that regulation today is in a
dialogue with the industry and sometimes
they're the industry's happy with the
progress that's made sometimes they wish
it would go faster and that's a natural
tension between private sector and
regulators but you know I think I think
that sometimes the concern that you know
the the in the intuition that as soon as
the regulator walks in the room they're
going to be livid and everyone's going
to jail is just not the state of affairs
in 2019 we we met with the SEC eight
times over the course of this past year
and I think you know for many others
this is ongoing dialogue so I think that
is a really good place and that that's
really important for people want to
participate as investors as well crypto
is just speculative assets that has no
real value to it and no one's using it
yeah yeah so on the using it front I
think
the analogy I like to give is so so
first of all a lot of people are you
know again we're talking about mainly
people who are not working full time in
the industry so for your listeners who
work full time in the industry we're not
talking about you you know I think for
many others for individuals families
institutions advisors you know as silly
as it sounds it's called currency so you
start from okay well if it's currency
show me how it's being used like
currency and this manifests itself and
I'm not buying coffee with it and the
reality is you know I don't think that
would got you backed is gonna work with
Starbucks to make that possible but that
that's not the most important thing and
and the mental model that I would
suggest for looking for use cases is not
what are all the places where it's not
better than the US dollar today but
rather there just needs to be one thing
that it's good at and here's the analogy
in 2007 everyone's using laptops and
desktops and along comes the iPhone a
new computing platform it's not the case
that the iPhone replaced all desktops
and laptops we still use desktops and
laptops for spreadsheets you know I pity
the individual just doing spreadsheets
on mobile for powerpoints writing
writing email mobile there's some other
things that are just way about our
mobile Maps uber taking photos wherever
you are and you do email on both and I
think similarly when we think about
public blockchains
the heuristic we should have is not has
it wiped out all other payment systems
all other currencies you know has a
replacement it doesn't have to it's
gonna coexist just like the iPhone
coexist with your laptop he just needs
to do it needs to find its Google Maps
it needs to have the one thing that oh
my gosh is so much better and there I
think we see burgeoning examples
specifically the most obvious one is
people using it to transport money
across borders that could be you know
fleeing inflation in Venezuela there was
a great on your times this venezuelan
economist who talked to the headline is
and you can look it up bitcoin saved my
family
and you know he's talking about moving
out of a million percent annualized
inflation it's gonna destroy his family
savings that's very real so being able
to get but also you know if you just
this I think two weeks ago you have five
hundred million dollars has moved across
the Bitcoin blockchain for a thirty six
bucks or something into minimus fee so I
think the thing it's doing a really
great job at is you're not buying coffee
you're not at the register in every
second counts you're happy for to wait
ten minutes when people forget to you're
not using dollars to buy coffee usually
right usually cut it yeah this is one of
the things that we go pretty deep with
people and just say listen it feels like
dollars raised denominated in dollars
it's it's a great user experience but
don't forget that you actually are
paying it off at the end of the month
right that's a pretty long settlement
time yeah and now there's great
advantages as to why to do it there
there's a very very good argument as to
impact the positive impact this had on
society etcetera but you are actually
not using dollars in that scenario so so
to the to the to the use cases I say
first as investors you know I'm worried
that we'll miss the vote the boat if we
wait for coffee what we need to see is
just a great use case for a or multiple
public blockchains and I think the
leading candidate today is some version
of you call remittance capital
expatriation there are two hundred and
sixty million people who change the
country they live in each year around
the world you know if you're moving from
you're moving your family from I'm gonna
say Indonesia to Spain oh my gosh you
know is there any moment where you could
simplify that or if you of course
there's a giant remains corridor between
the US and the Philippines is easier to
send some money that way
is it easier if your limit on venmo is
2,000 bucks and you have a friend or you
know a kid in college is it easier to
send in 5,000 bucks some other way so
and most of those platforms let people
don't know this but venmo
Apple pay PayPal they're not available
in these other marks right so it's in
the US we sit we say hey I'll just venmo
you right but I forget we did the
analysis and it's like the countries
that is not available and would shock
you right because it's just now they
have something else right but then
can't get sent to yes you know in Pisa
right for example like those two don't
they're not compatible with each other
yeah whereas when you look at something
like a Bitcoin right now you've got
something that is global globally
available as long as you have an
internet connection which i think is
really important is yes absolutely
that's that's how we think about what
even to be looking for is the heuristic
for progress and it is it is important
that people are looking to see progress
you can't just close your eyes but I
think it's important that you're being
realistic about what success looks like
and and and I think it's you know seeing
one two three of those use cases in it I
think we're seeing this day okay fine
you can miss me people use it but
they're just terrorists drug dealers and
yeah this is simple this is simple so I
mean the two things there first of all
the DEA said I believe this year that
less than 10 percent of activity on
blockchains is today illicit activity
it's it's fair to point out that that is
a part of the origin story of crypto and
in in in you know Silk Road and and in
that history but you know did you just
take the DA's word for it so you know
and then I think I think that the second
thing that that you know we point out
depending on the interest level the
audiences depending on the blockchain
you're using it's pretty trackable and
so I think what a lot of central banks
and governments are coming around to and
one of the reasons people are excited to
sort of sprint into central bank digital
currencies is oh wait a minute we don't
have to deal with cash we can give
people the flexibility of cash the bare
instrument that they can exchange
wherever they want whenever they want
with whoever they want but we can track
it we can't track the hundred dollar
bill
the choice currency of the drug dealers
is still physical cash right so so you
know so if you said to a regulator you
can you you don't have to restrain any
of those use cases but you can witness
them all you can surveil them all you
know then I think the regulator feels
good about that so so you know I think
increasingly this notion that you can
high nefarious transactions through the
Bitcoin blockchain say or another with
the exception of the ones that are
specific
trying to facilitate that will will fall
away and people realize it's not it's
not the best way to do that and and it's
a permanent ledger so they don't have to
get you this year there have to get you
next year they'll get you in ten years
like so so anyways so so that when I say
relevant consideration their aim AML
requirements in place for interacting
with the regulated part of the of the
ecosystem you know if you work with the
kind of party like us or like you you
know their diligence seeing who they're
trading with and and who they're buying
and selling from and there's AML
requirements there but more generally
that has reduced in part because it's
not a it's not the easiest way to get
away with something for sure
last one for you I heard that countries
that are not great with the United
States are heavily involved so mining is
controlled by China or Russia is really
interested in this or some other country
in the world that is trying to avoid
sanctions for example etc why do I want
to have something in my portfolio that
is being used by you know someone who's
not an ally of the United States in some
cases that's an interesting question I
mean I I do think here it's it's a bit
it's a bit like oil you know or even the
you know the dollar it's it's uh it can
be surveilled it can be enforced on the
US can extend its jurisdiction you can
limit the counterparties that you
interact with to ones that are regulated
ultimately if somebody wants to take a
hundred dollar bill into North Korea or
you know if if somebody uses oil to fund
it you know terrorist effort well my
favorite is I think was the drug office
of the UK or something like that they
did a study and Bloomberg published a
big report that said two trillion
dollars of you two trillion US dollars
per year is money laundered yeah well
and when they started looking through it
do you know they've got all the numbers
whatever you look at you're like wait a
minute
two trillion dollars is laundered and
the entire crypto market cap is like at
the time
like 250 bill right so we're talking
about literally connects the entire
market cap of crypto is being laundered
in yeah I mean I can see well I do think
that though the thing that you know to
many people they're like okay fine you
point out a blemish on the existing
system but we're in the existing system
so that's what it is but I don't have to
step into this new system and if the new
system is as bad as the existing system
why would I you know so but I think that
the the the improvement in the new
system is what we discussed which is
it's a transparent ledger everything
that's taking place in the ledger either
now or in the future can potentially be
acted on enforced on and that is an
advantage public box chains have towards
existing and compliance existing in
aboveboard context so the other one that
you didn't ask that we get all the time
got today was is a look people say that
this thing is scarce but I hear the
people just creating dozens of new
bitcoins that you know they're creating
there's hundreds of these Bitcoin things
now thousands there's thousands yeah you
know I went on coin market cab you see
many bitcoins and you know they're there
what we tried articulate is it's a
little bit like saying my uncle just
launched a blog Wikipedia's in trouble
like there there there are there's
something like three million apps on the
App Store people mostly use ten there's
like 350 million websites on the
internet people mostly only use Google
Amazon Wikipedia YouTube Facebook the
mirror because it's software the
marginal cost of creating a new one is
de minimis and so the same thing with
crypto people are gonna create new ones
that doesn't have any bearing on the
reality of the existing ones I think
that the the mental mode that one has to
be in to understand so there's there's
two types of technology companies
generally one is Intel they make some
break through an IP and they figure out
how to put more transistors on a small
nanometer of silicon they create like
the world's first fabrication lab for
doing that and then they go to you and
they say would you like more speed for
less money and you go dang that sounds
good and and that's the sort of IP hard
core technology type of tech company
there's another type of tech company
which is the uber Airbnb whatsapp
Facebook's eBay's of the world there
it's not explicitly that they made some
scientific breakthrough but rather
they've gathered a multi-sided market
place that has sort of a centrifugal
flywheel that causes it to just be
superior as a simple example
HPE created webOS a mobile phone
operating system you know ever heard of
it yeah yeah you have to imagine is you
know the the the the consumer isn't
gonna buy it unless it is apps and the
app developer isn't gonna write an app
for it unless they're consumers mm-hm
you and I could create you know could
rewrite some of the uber software but
the driver is not going to download the
app unless they know they're gonna get
calls from riders and the riders not
gonna make calls unless the drivers on
there so so similarly with public
machines they're not I think that that
because it's so unfamiliar and there's
so much jargon and crypto people have an
inclination to believe it's the Intel
type of tech which is like is patentable
it's not its effect it's a network
effect type of tech it's the uber type
of tech and so if somebody is somebody
Forks if somebody fork set you know
Bitcoin and and you make some
modification or somebody you know writes
a new protocol and expands on the prior
art you still have to go get all of the
the constituents you have to get the
miners you have to get the app
developers you have to get somebody
create futures on top you have to you
know you have to get the custodians to
support it you have to get people to
actually want to buy it and so that
creates a lot of defense abilities so to
summarize like the app store or the web
the mere creation of a new one doesn't
matter any of itself doesn't change
anything
and the defensibility doesn't come from
sort of novel IP it comes from the
network effect that emerges around the
protocol got it before we wrap up with a
round five
you guys are one of I think two or three
now who have been slowly beating down
the door
yeah we're for the Bitcoin ETF approval
in the United States yeah maybe just
give us kind of a why are you guys
interested in getting that approved yeah
and then where do we stand today with
with it imperious yeah applications yeah
it's a very so the why is two things one
it's a very simple piece of
infrastructure that a lot of that would
simplify for a lot of investors getting
access to the asset class you know there
are many investors who say look we're
interested we see it could do something
in portfolio but we can't you know we
can't do it through these other
structures we use mutual funds we use
etf's
this is gonna be a one percent
allocation we're not gonna rewrite our
compliance manual we're not gonna
rewrite our workflow we're not gonna
hire this new personnel we're not gonna
undertake a two-week long it needs to
slot in just like the same bar that we
applied to everything else so it's it's
sort of a bridge that needs to be built
to for some people to come across and
that's really big deal the other for
some you know there's there's some large
institutions who said to us you know
even you know hedge fund manager
selection people said we'll probably
first allocate to a Bitcoin ETF I said
why that way that's crazy
and he said well realistically if
Bitcoin ETF launches it means the the
SEC did diligence on all of these
aspects cost be mocked manipulation
volume pricing and the exposure is
enough for us so it'll just but it'll be
really valuable to have the SEC stamp on
it and so I think those are the two
reasons that it's so high-stakes it
opens up you know huge group of people
who just can't walk across until that
happens and then the second is it does
it does
and this is why it's you know it's such
a big deal to the SEC they don't take it
lightly it does represent the SEC has
done homework and said that this is
feasible and that matters to other
investors so so we're where is where is
the Bitcoin ETF journey at the
winklevosses kicked off the journey back
in 2013 with the first filing we're very
crazy by the way that's how early they
started incredible incredible yes it's
almost hard to imagine
and then our filing is the most recent
so our filing was had a disapproval
order in October and then that was
stayed so the staff that works for the
Commission issues the disapproval order
and then the Commission stayed the
disapproval and is now examining it so
that's that's sort of the latest with
Bitcoin each yes our filing and and that
the backdrop I would say so so this year
we did it we try to contribute a huge
amount to helping the SEC build build
their view and address the concerns they
have we wrote 500 pages white paper we
went you know eight times there were
over half a dozen industry constituents
who wrote letters advocating for our
filing and and and the ability to do
this effectively today that includes
coinbase watching Association number of
others and you know what we saw in their
response was what we've experienced I
think what everyone understands for the
SC which is they're paying attention
they're spending time on it and they
have a nuanced understanding and they
still have some concerns there's not
much more you can ask for from a
regulator you know their job is to
protect is protect investors and the
gift that we all get as an industry is
the fact that they've staffed people on
this it's a budget constrained
organization people were furloughed at
the beginning of this year when you know
when the government ran out of funding
people forget
people forget yeah so the fact that
they've even staffed people on this is a
huge gift to crypto and and and and
obviously to the the ETF efforts and and
I feel grateful for the people
internally at the SEC who are doing this
work it's not easy mm-hmm it's also not
easy for a pension to allocate to crypto
it's not easy for an endowment to decide
to allocate to crypto and so it's
definitely not easy for the for the SEC
to say we're come for this but they're
moving along so then the question is
okay well they've been moving along for
a long time yeah what should we make of
this and you know I truthfully I would
like them to move faster even I really
respect the work they're doing because I
think that this for many investors would
save people from a lot of pain a lot of
harm and a lot of the risks embedded in
the other services that people are using
because they can't do it this way
so they sort of been you know forced
through omission are being forced to the
fringes of solutions but you could say
okay you know so they're spending time
what should make you know that the the
journey here where are we in the journey
and and here we like to provide his
context Matt our head of research one of
the foremost experts on the ETF's wrote
the ETF section of the CFA a great
partner in educating on ETS leads our
work on the ETF you know points out that
the first gold ETF took two to three
years the first fixed income took like
four five six years
first leverage took seven years first
non-transparent which was just approved
this year took nine years crypto is five
to six years in depending on how you
account for all not you know for all
these novel different novel structures
it's taken time and so the question is
not you know will they disapprove this
finally the question is are they are
they you know is the thinking moving
along a devastating outcome would have
been on the filing if they demanded that
we withdraw it if they said do not make
us write a public memo or because they
don't want you know they just don't care
and they don't even want to spend the
time right another another bad outcome
would be if they wrote a two-page memo
says you know not safes manipulated yeah
they didn't know how many twelve pages
what is the last time you were a hundred
I mean you you acutely know how long it
takes to write things
now imagine writing 112 pages and having
30 people weigh in on it about something
you don't care about yeah not gonna
happen
yeah yeah right and and its public
precedent you'll be asked about for the
next five years that's a huge
undertaking so why do you do that you do
that because you're working through a
lot of issues and you want to
communicate out we're working mm-hmm
help us solve these things so so we're
we're grateful for that response we you
know we think that the market would
really benefit from from something
coming to market we think that you can
securely operate an ETF tends to be very
about that we've been operating funds
for two years we believe that you can
securely operate in the market we've
written a lot to that extent and we're
committed to seeing this thing through
so that's the latest on that yeah we're
all cheering for you man come on it's
it's ways things where I think that
people will look back and say oh of
course an ETF was gonna get approved
right and they'll kind of forget all the
hard work that goes and yes so it's
important to kind of talk about the hard
work that goes I do you think it's true
I mean you took awhile to get fixed to
get bond ETFs approved that's what I'm
saying I'm saying it took a while to get
bond ETFs approved you know and exactly
your point you would say what yeah of
course they were gonna do that right all
right rapid-fire what's the most
important company encrypt your other
than bitwise it's I would say it's
hands-down coinbase why I think that
coin base provides air cover for so many
other companies in two ways number one
it demonstrates to capital allocators
that you can build a giant business a
giant valuable business and you need
those there's tentpoles the success
stories for people to fund new
businesses and I think that is sort of
the shining example that people look at
today and say wow I wish I'd invested in
that business and look they've
successfully built a giant business in
this space the second is that they you
know they they're above board they play
by the rules they interact proactive
with regulators they register they get
licenses and they have massive scale and
so they're doing all of that with
massive scale and and I think that is I
think it's I think sometimes they're you
know like so many other things once it
becomes familiar start to take it for
granted start to you know notice the
things that were frustrated with but I
think if you remove coinbase from crypto
I think that that on the regulatory
front and on the private capitalisation
of new ventures you lose a lot so I
claim because I would say for those
reasons what's the one regulation you
would change or improve if you could
Wow you know I'm so so commissioner
Clayton's looking at it but I do think
that there's this interesting aspect of
the 33 act this cruise act of 33 which
divides the universe into accredited and
non-accredited and it defines a credit
investors is having over two and a
thousand dollars in income over a
million dollars in net worth in 1933
materially what it means today there's
about 11 million accredited investors
today is really you have sort of like
the people who can do what they want and
then you have and then you have everyone
else and as increasingly you know this
gets to a much bigger trend that's
playing out right now but but in 2000 in
the year 2000 there were 8500 publicly
listed exchange traded companies today
there's 3,500 the Wilshire 5000 index
does not have 5000 companies in it so
companies are not listing the stained
private for longer that the amount of
time the average venture-backed company
stays private is gone from 4.2 years to
five and a half they're getting their
capital privately they're staying
private people take them seriously
privately you know nobody nobody
questions how serious everybody is
because they're private of course and
and so a lot more happening in private
markets but private markets are only
available to credit investors and so but
Commissioner Clayton is is specifically
looking into this which is how can we
how can we provide the protections that
prevent people from from from losing
their shirts which are very important
and at the same time a lot of people
access to the fact that a lot that a lot
of value is shifting to these
alternatives to private markets so so I
think that's the one that feels to me
like there's a sensible there's a
sensible opportunity to improve that's
one that jumps out at me I'm sure that
there's a library I agree the accredited
vaishu the accredited investor laws are
in violation of the American Dream in my
opinion what's the most controversial
high take right there very it's true
yeah well we wrote into law you have to
be rich to get rich mm-hmm right yeah
yeah there's definitely something to I
mean I think
what has really has really become you
know in sharp relief over the last 20
years is there's two ways to make money
you can make money from capital and you
make money from labor and they're two
very different ways they're taxed
differently it's two different tax codes
for capital gains and versus weight
religion labor wages and which one's
more advantageous yeah so so you know
times change and I think that you know
while maybe the mix of capital gains
versus wage labor in the 30s was one
thing you know yeah I think today what's
the most important book you've ever read
that's a great question all I do is
great questions so many great questions
Boyd done this 200 times go ahead yeah
Jose laughing in the corner for everyone
who who didn't hear ya there's there's a
non-space is ready to embarrass that I
call that now we're looking at you he's
been mostly laughing at my jokes though
you know nothing I'll tell you I'll tell
you the book more recently that's such a
big question you know I love reading so
much opportunity this is a book called
engines and move markets have you heard
of that book engines that move markets
it's it's written by former I believe
CIO or chief economist for Franklin
Templeton okay I'll steer and gnar and I
believe and I'm embarrassed to not have
said it correctly it's called engines
move markets and it looks at some of the
most important technological
breakthroughs over the last 150 years
through the lens of an investor who was
there at the time so it looks at the
railroad it looks at the electrical grid
it looks at the Telegraph look to the
telephone
it looks at at the automobile in which
the PC and at which things like gross
margins did the investors that backed
these companies make money where the
business is profitable were there a
bunch were there a few was the first
mover was the incumbent and I think it
you know most people are familiar with
the stories of many of these different
forms and some of the characters
involved Edison and the railroads
Rockefeller etc but they're not they've
never actually thought about it from the
lens of you know of allocating capital
someone comes along and says I have the
an idea for a telegraph that transmits
voice and I'm raising $100,000 there's a
great quote from the CEO of Western
Union who said you know who turned down
$400,000 Alexander Graham Bell's offered
to sell the patents so what does anyone
what use does anyone have for a toy like
this and within 10 years ATT bought
Western Union which is the time had been
the largest company in the country so I
think one of the reasons crazy-crazy
yeah it's totally it's totally crazy I
love history more generally I I had the
opportunity to TA the history of
business classes at Wharton and I love
love history love love business history
I love this book in particular because I
think it it just shows you the behind
the scenes of how a lot that feels fixed
in the world came into existence and how
uncertain it was and this sort of
arbitrariness of the of the path the
path that things took so I highly
recommend that book engines that move
mark engines and move markets aliens
believer or non-believer believe I
I think if I was Betty money that I
would bet money on there being aliens
why there's two to two things that point
to you number one humans always think
that they know and then they're always
wrong there's like the only thing that
humans are consistently good at the
world is flat oh no it's not yes small
detail yes we watched that one for a
little while you know bloodletting cure
for you know ailment oh actually not at
all so there's nine planets wait nope
now there's 1400 yeah Ida fault too you
know unless there's strong evidence that
something is not possible you default
impossible there's a Fermi's paradox or
drinks equation so the reason why I ask
this question is it started out as if
aliens are real so you have to just okay
they're real yeah do they have pets or
are they
one single species and there's no
concept of alien pets I love this
question that's where that question came
from originally people forget I used to
ask every single person do you also you
would define the the the smallest Union
you what is the minimal criteria at
which you would consider something an
alien this your show you define Pro I
mentioned consciousness I think with
consciousness regardless of form size
and then you know
but are there alien pets I'm on the side
of Helium pets all right so am I so I
but I'm just that's my thing is if you
if you've looked at all the movies yeah
every sci-fi there's no there there
might be maybe that's why they're always
invading that are together they're sad
that you know if they had dogs well
here's a good one for you do we want
them to come in contact with us in all
of human history
yeah invaders you matter you advantage I
mean I think they're yeah no no and you
know it's actually interesting right now
there's sort of a burgeoning you know
private space sector that's emerging
commercialization of space undertakings
but you know even simply you could see
the still ends of SpaceX and Blue Origin
and Virgin Galactic and these are
private and it's it's funny because in
my mind there's some some parallels to
explorers in European explorers you know
if you if you imagine what Christopher
Columbus or some of the other names for
francis drake from that period we're
doing that you know they're they're
going on very long journeys you could
easily die just in the process of
getting in the direction of where you're
going and you don't know what's on the
other side and some of those journeys
were financed privately by merchant
banks and and essentially wealthy
families but but
nobles and and it is kind of interesting
to draw a parallel the the the form has
changed its not sailboats but now it's
rocket ships and and they're they're
going you know the journey is perilous
today it's being privately financed the
jurisdiction that countries have over
the where they're going is kind of
unclear so it's likely to be the Wild
West in terms of how rule is enforced
you who gets to claim Mars first three
it's great oh yeah yeah can get into all
kinds of questions that I I don't think
people really want to know the answers
to yeah I do
do you think do you think do you think
in in our lifetime
people are living either in space in
some you know sort of an International
Space Station type
so obviously Virgin Galactic is is
pushing the the frontier of space
tourism do you think people are living
in space or out on another planet
there are lifetimes I think humans will
make it there in our lifetime so let's
I'm 31 I'm assuming you're similar right
so let's say that we've got let's be
real ambitious to say we got 80 years in
our life so perfect so we're I'm not
walking out with you don't make Jyothi
VOC locusts luck but no so the long
story
no but if you think about that so 50
years we are what 60 years give or take
since man went to the moon so the odds
that we can get to Mars probably happens
in our lifetimes I don't know if it is
like true colonization like that like
there's a difference between like we
basically probe or is it possible to get
somewhere and then like here you senator
your family right right and the the
colonization I think is so that one's a
little bit tougher for me to see that
happening but getting therefore I'm like
pretty confident that we'll we'll get
there and I left mm-hmm
I'd love to know some of your other
prediction
by the future class can ask you two more
questions yeah well actually ice how we
end you get ask me questions so go ahead
great well I've got a cryptic question
but I don't ask you to or the question
of the future there's a hundred and
seventy odd countries today nation
states do you think we have more or less
than 100 by the end of your lifetime
170 170 today the Mauritius is this
island country yeah obviously so I've
got a nuanced answer I think that there
will still be the quote country but the
definition of a country will change and
what I mean by that is it won't be so
much tied to the physical borders of
like this is my land get out it'll be
much more a group of people who choose
to have themselves governed under a
collective rule right so I got like
Estonia is a good example it's like all
of a sudden the study is taking
citizenships from people who have never
even been to Estonia is that right like
a digital citizenship so like you could
become a digital citizen of Estonia I'd
never go within their physical borders
yeah and so like I don't think that the
country of Estonia goes away yeah but
all of a sudden wait a minute like their
sovereignty and how they think about
citizenship all that starts to shift
yeah the harder part is like what does
it become I'm not sure but I do think
that the the idea of what a what a
country is changes in that environment
where you no longer have the physical
constraint which is you don't have to
co-locate these people but you just have
to share a set of values a set of
standards you would actually expect it
to be more of these right because the
the barrier to entry would be lower and
you could also potentially a multiple
membership I mean that would that would
depend but you you could actually see
like well California is a gonna be a
country by like the next election or
what is it what is it
yeah Sims raber's got three three
countries coming out of California but
think about the Internet the Internet's
a country right it's like like I think a
lot about this idea of everyone is a
citizen of the internet and it's largest
country in the world and yeah there's
some ramifications of the physical place
in which you access the others but it's
kind of like they're ready player one
like you go into the portal yeah right
and once you're in the portal yeah here
we go yeah and so I think that it's you
know is Twitter a digital country
because it has its own fiefdom its own
rules its everyone's a citizen we all
act along it there's a quote-unquote
government right when it's Twitter
censoring platform you say the same
thing about you know super nation-states
and you say something about Islam or
Judaism or Catholicism or sort of an
interesting spectrum there but you know
conventionally the Internet allows a
longtail a fragmentation to emerge
that's you know over a long tail of
people to become drivers everybody along
tail people to open hospitality you two
belong tail of talk shows and WordPress
long tail publications Facebook long
tail of communities so you can imagine
imagine sort of a long tail of more
formal human organizations there's a
great article do you know Jesse Walden
at Andreessen I know who he is he wrote
a great article on cryptid networks as
coops as a digital way of instantiating
a co-op so you know Land O'Lakes is a
co-op there number of other coughs sort
of you know among us today but the
preferred way of organizing humans is a
corporation or a limited partnership but
you know his argument is that a protocol
is wave form you know a co-op is sure
it's at rules you mentioned air BB I'll
give you a great yeah but somebody said
to me they said Airbnb is the largest
hospitality school in the world
Wow cuz what they do they taught people
how to run hotels yeah or run rentals
yeah and they're usually people who had
no formal training
yeah and Airbnb said you're some best
practices that's so fascinating do berm
the labor force the largest taxi yeah
school in the world so many perilous I
mean once when I have Ford in the early
part of the 20th century in like 1918
had a school there's a Ford school Ford
buy they also had a bank and also built
housing crazy and you see you have Ford
credit there's a Ford store so yeah so I
mean the reason I love business history
is because nothing is new nothing new it
just changes colors and it just changes
clothes but so you know yeah the idea
that the weight of conceptualizing
airbnb as both labor training program as
well as as well as what are the
questions you got another question I
want to ask you was on the crypto front
and I was curious ask you from from your
from your venture seat how do you think
about what are their particular pockets
of crypto that are most interesting to
you today and has it changed over the
over the last year change the whole time
I'm sure changes I'm sure that changes
all the time in there's a lot of
enthusiasm for new protocols well
obviously one point there's a lot of
enthusiasm for custodians at one point
there's a curious I'm curious yeah it
seems there is it tend to be more so I
tend to think of it as we've got some
very core thesis those thesis plays out
in a lot of different ways so to the
court like probably the the two core
thesis we have is every stock bond
currency commodity will be digitized
over time and the second is that humans
will trust algorithms and software over
other humans so take the algorithms and
software over other humans first that
could plays out Bitcoin as a store of
value like I trust that this software
system is going to correctly store and
secure my value for long periods of time
okay well then you can also go to what
about defy right there's a whole world
there of me trusting software over
humans right but again do your point
about like nothing's new yeah well like
I trust Google Maps for directions I
don't trust the person on the street
anymore
right yeah like I'm gonna ask somebody a
question hey do you know you know how
many World Series to the New York
Yankees would and us three people in New
York and literally you might get three
different answers but Google always
right right and so it's like I trust
that algorithm or that software and so
if you go down the line I think that
that's like a really key theme but it
plays out in a lot of different ways
when you go to every stock bond currency
commodity gets digitized that is playing
out in people who are digitizing them
people who are providing custodianship
for them people who are providing more
places for them you almost have to think
if it's like the thesis is a bucket and
within those buckets are the
applications or the execution of that
idea but one that I'm becoming much more
I think excited about that people aren't
talking about yeah is using till now it
was using this technology about this
being decentralization governance etc as
the escape hatch more privacy and
individual freedoms hmm so like you were
talking about earlier governments
historically have done nothing but
continue to encroach on individual
freedoms everything from simple things
like there used to not be a federal
income tax right introduced at a time of
need right and it never went away
things around surveillance state you
know you just why do we need that
security camera on the street I wonder
now there's 20 of them right you know so
what ends up happening is there's
usually pretty decent explanations as to
why to do this at some point it's just
that the slippery slope is slippery
right and you you just don't go back
yeah so right the only way to go back or
to reset or to give back freedom it's
not to argue with the government or
fight the government etc because
actually they're doing what the rational
thing for a government to do is they
actually are trying to protect people
it's just that there's a balance between
protection and freedom what you have to
do is you have to give people tools that
they then an opt into right and so if
you look at like Bitcoin versus
essential Bank digital currency there's
going to be tons of people who use the
central bank digital currency because
it's easy there government back sale
whatever but there's gonna be a group of
people who opt out of that system and
opt into the more individual freedom
privacy type world and so like I don't
know exactly how that plays out but
something that I'm starting to pay more
attention to because it feels like it's
applicable to money it's applicable to
surveillance it's applicable to your
data it's applicable to though the way
that you interact with things right so
you know if we move to this automated
world and let's say that you're driving
your car down the street and rather than
pay your taxes your car just pays for
what it uses yeah besides you're just
paying sensors along the way
well like who's getting that data right
you know you can really quickly see this
like kind of Orwellian dystopian type
world that I don't think is like five
years away mmm
but like if you walk backwards let's say
it takes 30 years to come we're doing
some things today that are gonna
accelerate us getting there yeah so I
think that's a big one
yeah and then the last one is this idea
of the people who have nothing can
leapfrog the people who have something
and so if you look at like mobile
banking in the Eastern African countries
right and Payson did a great job going
from we have nothing to we have better
mobile banking than most people in the
US right
and so like money's one thing but
there's a whole bunch of other things
around technology and you and I were
both at Facebook around the time we're
like they were running out of users on
the internet what they do let's go get
for a bunch of people can be like you
know and let's go give internet to
everyone well now I release the
population of the world we're like now
as these technologies get built whether
it's a Bitcoin whether it's you know the
financial services or protocols or
whatever they're going to be built and
scaled on the back of that connectivity
that didn't exist 20 years ago so I
actually think that companies can grow
faster now yeah right and they can
become global from day one because
people forget already you don't talk
about history business a company in the
u.s. used to penetrate the US market and
then like let's have a board meeting
should we have international expansion
this year
well now like you just turn a website on
and bam your global yeah and so I think
like those are all trends that come
together and then oh yeah summarize it
with one other piece I think is
important is it's not just about
blockchain or crypto hmm it's the
melding of a lot of different
technologies so machine learning is not
going to be siloed from a blockchain or
from voice or from you know some other
technology it's really going to be the
culmination of a lot of these are the
melding of them together and if you go
and you look at you know Amazon's a
great example Google's a great example
you know even Facebook etc it wasn't
just like hey I'm gonna build this
Internet company yeah there was a whole
bunch of other technologies that we're
all getting integrated with the quote
internet that allowed some of those
companies to be successful so I don't
think that's gonna change now either mmm
Wow do you think um at what when you
think we'll see a country where people
just start using maybe it's a stable
coin maybe it's some other coin but it's
integrated into what they do and I think
that we're gonna see two different types
of countries be the first we're gonna
see like the China the government is
heavily incentivizing and little
surveillance action going on you know
this is good for you wink wink stomp
stomp
you know we're watching today so I think
that's gonna be one attack vector to get
there which I think most people in the
Democratic kind of American values world
disagrees with but the other one is
going to actually be the countries that
have very innovative leadership but
realize they have very little to lose
and so you see like BVI recently tried
to digitize or tokenize their currency
you've seen countries that are under
heavy sanctions basically throw the Hail
Mary and so I think like that's the the
world where it goes back to was that the
is a Jim Collins book good to great
which basically arm sorry what was the
saying the good is the enemy of great
I'm sorry so good is the enemy of great
and like if you think about the greatest
good
no good as the enemy of great okay so
like the u.s. is good but we don't have
a great payment infrastructure we don't
have great you know monetary policy all
this stuff but it's good enough it
serves the purpose you and I need right
it's worked for so long that we get
complacent yeah somebody who has nothing
who has no infrastructure who has no you
know discipline a monetary policy etc
they are able to leapfrog us and become
quote-unquote great but if you go back
the US was great at one point right in
the sense of when we came and the
Industrial Revolution and all this stuff
like we leapfrogged others yes and so
it's this constant competition in a free
market globally that we've got to remain
I think vigilant yes and Mark usko has
this thing and I'm gonna mess up the
numbers but you'll get the general gist
for every one engineer that graduates in
the United States I think that there are
twelve engineers that graduate in South
Korea but for every one lawyer they
graduate we graduate forty-five right
and the his point is and again those
those data points probably someone's
gonna tell you note we may say wrong put
that general trend right and the point
of the story or joke is there a country
of wealth creation yeah whereas we are
starting to become a country of wealth
redistribution right and I think you
know it all goes back to this one point
kind of enclosing which is I have the
fortune talk to a lot of investors and
investors that frankly one shouldn't be
in the same room as me right and two
that I admire because they're good at
the thing that they do Yeah right
and I'm usually there to try to convince
them about Bitcoin or crypto or you know
whatever but I always ask them one
question yeah and I say what is the
thing that separates the top two or
three people on your strategy from the
top one percent so the absolute
world-class best and the people who are
really really [ __ ] good yeah and
historically the most common answer is
something to the effect of they cut
their losers faster than everyone else
and they press they're winners hard
than everyone else right so brochure
strategy across the boys the second best
answer or the most common answer has
something to do with following
demographics which is very similar to
the market conversation when you're
building a company pick the right market
yeah well when you're investing yeah all
the demographics picked the right market
so I think that there's a lot of
parallels there that just people forget
right we all think we're smarter than
then we really are all this kind of
stuff but in plain sight to some extent
demographics yeah I mean like imagine if
it's just hey I'm gonna invest in the
public equities in countries that have
fast growth rates of young populations
I have no clue what that looked like
over the last 50 years my guess is this
probably performed pretty well over the
last 400 years of history if you either
through subjects or population had the
most pop you know you generally did well
and I think we're about to see that
we're trying to yeah it's definitely the
story with us it's easier to get per
capita from 30,000 40,000 on a larger
number of people absolutely so yeah I
think demographics are huge so makes
sense yeah all right man listen thank
you so much for coming to do this
absolutely I'm a huge fan of what you
guys are building obviously we have
invested we are partnering everything
where can people go find out more about
a bit wise bit wise investments calm our
Twitter is a bit wise invest where can
they find you I'm hunter a bit wise
investments calm and I'm at each
hoarsely on Twitter
each o or SLE wa s Lu Wow wow that's
extraordinary you got that people mess
it up all the time where they where they
switch the E&L that's right yeah yeah
well they don't pay attention attention
no detail until now thanks so much thank
you thank you